I think the president for all his
support particularly on some of the
travel restrictions that I think has
made it easier for us to monitor folks
who have been traveling particularly in
parts of Asia and really appreciate
devices a second time you've been in
Florida just as he's been leaving the
task force so we really appreciate his
support as many of you know you know
Florida had its first two covin 19
length fatalities yesterday and so we
are stressing to folks that if you look
at how this virus impacts people the
folks who are elderly and have
underlying medical conditions are at
much greater risk to have serious
complications so we've been working hard
with our hospitals and our nursing homes
assisted living facilities but we've
also wanted to spread the message to the
people as a whole
follow the CDC's guidelines guidance on
this they recommend for people who are
elderly of these health conditions you
know stay at home if you need if you
need you know avoid large crowds make
sure you have a couple weeks of supplies
of medical and food just in case you're
in a situation where you need to isolate
so those are prudent steps that people
can take and that will help our efforts
here as we work to contain the spread of
the virus but thanks again for coming we
appreciate your leadership
Thank You governor I want to I want to
thank you for bringing together leaders
in the cruise line industry for an
important discussion about how we keep
passengers
communities that come from in our
country city the president is grateful
for the spirit of collaboration
represented in this room and I look very
much forward to artists
how we help you make this industry
that's safer governor I want to thank
you for your your leadership I'm also
very grateful for Senator Rick Scott
Senator Marco Rubio and their swift
efforts in in passing more than a
billion dollars in funding for America's
response to the corona virus let me also
let me thank all the public officials
who are here as well and I'm pleased to
be joined by the head of CDC as well as
the Acting Secretary of Homeland
Security that Chad wolf we're really
here to have a very substantive
conversation with an industry that has
found itself at the center in so many
ways of America's response to the corona
virus I'm looking forward to hearing
about the industry's recommendations
about about what what more you can do
what more we can do together to protect
the American people I know it goes
without saying President Trump has no
higher priority than the health and
safety and well-being of the American
people it's the reason why from from the
first advent of the corona virus on
America he president launched a
whole-of-government approach but as
evidenced here today it's not just a
whole-of-government approach bringing
the full resources the federal
government really a whole of America
approach and in this last week in
addition to the meeting today here the
president directed me to have with the
cruise line industry executives we've
met with leaders of the pharmaceutical
industry to talk about the development
of therapeutics and a vaccine we've
talked to leaders in the nursing home
industry we've talked to the leaders of
commercial labs and and I know I speak
with President Trump when I say we
couldn't be more great
with the spirit of cooperation and all
of the American businesses that we've
engaged and their desire to put with the
health of America first
from early on President Trump took
decisive and unprecedented action to
respond to the spread of the corona
virus the president declared a public
health emergency he suspended all travel
from China and we launched a quarantine
efforts for Americans that would be
returning including Americans returning
from a cruise line
he established travel advisories in
parts of Italy and South Korea and we
now are are screening one hundred
percent of all individuals who take
direct flights from any Airport in Italy
or South Korea before they board planes
to come to the United States of America
the president has also directed us and
HHS has done yeoman's work expanding
testing now doctors can prescribe tests
to any American regardless of their
symptoms and at the present moment we've
distributed more than 1 million tests
and in cooperation with those same
commercial labs that I mentioned we'll
be expanding access to tests in the
weeks ahead to every American I'm proud
to say though governor as you know here
in Florida every state in the country's
state lab can now do coronavirus testing
now let me just speak to the corona
virus itself and thanks to the decisive
leadership of President Trump the strong
partnership with state leaders local
health officials the American people
deserve to know that the risk of
contracting the corona virus for the
average American remains low that being
said we are going to continue to lean
into this effort to call on industry to
call every agency of
to deal with it the truth is that for
the majority of or I know the head of
CDC is here for whatever the number
would be for ninety six ninety seven
percent of Americans who even contract
the disease they they will be treated
they will have flu-like symptoms and
they're fully recovered but governor I
want to thank you for your particular
emphasis here in Florida and your focus
on our seniors because people here in
Florida deserve to know that our data
shows that seniors with serious
underlying health conditions are the
most vulnerable to serious medical
outcomes and so for anyone within the
sound of my voice if if you are yourself
a senior citizen with a serious
underlying medical condition or if you
have a loved one with a serious
underlying medical condition it is just
a good time to practice common sense
just to protect the your health the
health of your family and the health of
the community but I'm here today to
speak particularly about the unique
challenges facing a cruise line industry
and to be here with so many leaders and
have an opportunity to speak about how
we can work together to make passengers
your cruise the communities they come
from in our country safer is a is a
great privilege for me in many ways
Florida is the heart of the cruise line
industry we recognize that it's a
destination not just for Americans but
for people around the world and I know
to date Florida's efforts have
preparedness on the coronavirus have
made a difference as we've seen in
recent week cruise ships have been
especially vulnerable to the spread of
the corona virus some forty nine
Americans that we returned home were on
the cruise ship Diamond Princess cruise
ship the Grand Princess as you all are
aware is as we speak
word off the coast of California and has
been so since Wednesday night
we have I'm pleased to report working
closely with the Governor of California
and all of our health officials
developed a plan which is being
implemented this weekend to bring the
ship into a non commercial port all
passengers and crew will be tested for
the corona virus and quarantined as
appropriate those that require
additional medical attention will also
receive it let me say again while while
the risk to the average American of
contracting the corona virus remains low
it is it is essential that we find ways
to to mitigate that risk to prevent the
spread of the corona virus and I'm here
today on behalf of President Trump to
learn ways that this industry the cruise
line industry can work with our health
officials at the federal level here at
the state level with port authorities to
give you passengers communities and our
country safe and healthy but I want to
promise you under president Trump's
leadership we're going to continue to
bring the full resources of the federal
government to bear in confronting the
spread of the corona virus and we look
forward to the support and assistance of
this industry in particular in the days
ahead as we put the health and
well-being of America first so with that
I thank you very much and I look forward
to a conversation
mr. president secretary mayor's thank
you very much for the opportunity
we are here to listen and learn and work
with you and your team so we can build
on our proven safety record leverage the
first-rate medical facilities that exist
on every cruise ship we follow our
public health protocols where we've
worked under the guidance of CDC for at
least 50 years and where most of the
materials that guide us are publicly
available most if not all on our cruise
industry Association website given the
significance of travel and tourism it is
critical that Americans keep traveling
and yes we also recognize that this is
an unprecedented situation covert 19th
our commitment here today and going
forward is to work closely with
government and to go above and beyond
anything we are currently doing to
screen even more stringently to prevent
those who should not be allowed to board
to monitor test and care for those who
are on board and to transition and help
pay for any sick guests or crew to move
to locations staffed and equipped to
handle Kovac 19 cases we will work
aggressively with government to further
develop and strengthen all necessary
protocols for prevention for detection
and for care mr. vice president we look
forward all of us who are here today to
having the meaningful discussion that
you reflected on thank you for this
opportunity
to anyone else